[Music]
the falcon in the winter soldier is full
of everything that makes the mcu special
including a ton of easter eggs from
references to past movies to homages to
the comic books that inspired the mcu
the disney plus show is bursting with
small details
here are some you might have missed the
falcon in the winter soldier opens with
a stunning action set piece featuring
the falcon performing a daring rescue
if the leader of the airborne kidnappers
looks familiar to you there's a very
good reason
that's none other than georges batroc
the dangerous mercenary who steve rogers
fights in the opening scenes of captain
america the winter soldier
he is played in both the film and the
falcon in the winter soldier by mma
legend george st
pierre in winter soldier captain america
runs up against batroc while rescuing
hostages aboard a shield ship which
batroc is hijacked
of course comic readers know batrock
better as batroc the leaper
a goofy kickboxing master has been a
thorn in captain america's side since
his debut in 1966's tales of suspense
number 75
putting sam wilson up against a classic
captain america baddie thus showing that
the falcon is just as capable of steve
rogers when it comes to taking on
supervillain threats is a candy way for
the falcon and the winter soldier to set
the stage early
you may not believe it yet but sam
wilson is absolutely steve's equal
just ask batrock in the falcon and the
winter soldier bucky barnes isn't sam
wilson's only partner in crime fighting
the falcon also teams up with a young
american gi named joaquin torres
in the first episode of the series
torres provides sam with operational
support while he's tussling with
batroc's forces
he later infiltrates a flag smash rally
in order to figure out what the
terrorist organization is up to
joaquin's connection to the falcon goes
much deeper than mere friendship though
torres made his comics debut in 2015's
captain america sam wilson
he emerges during a period in which sam
wilson has taken over steve rogers's
superhero identity
as a mexican-american living in arizona
torres is concerned about the well-being
of the immigrant community
unfortunately joaquin's good intentions
attract the attention of the sons of the
serpent
a racist terrorist group that capture
him and ship him off to dr carl malus
for experimentation
malice uses the dna from wilson's actual
falcon red wing to mutate torres giving
him wings and the same psychic link with
red wing that wilson enjoys
eventually wilson rescues torres but the
mutations are permanent
thus torres takes on the mantle of the
falcon and becomes the new captain
america's faithful sidekick
some people some people they think that
he's
in a secret base on the moon looking
down
over us the conspiracy theory torres
shares about steve rogers is not as
silly as it sounds
in marvel comics all sorts of characters
live on the moon most notably the moon
is home to the inhumans a genetically
enhanced offshoot of human race
technically the inhumans are already
part of the mcu they're the subject of
2017's short-lived inhuman series which
received four reviews and was cancelled
very quickly
uatu the watcher a mysterious alien
being who observes human history but is
forbidden from interfering
also lives on earth's biggest satellite
most likely however taurus line is a sly
reference to none other than nick fury
in the comics fury spends a few years on
the moon where he takes over owatu's
responsibilities
in the lionwide crossover known as
original sin fury kills owatu and steals
one of his eyes in order to solve an
outer space mystery
as punishment the rest of the watchers
imprison fury on the moon dub him the
unseen and force him to watch over earth
helpless to assist as further
catastrophes unfold
thankfully for fury his punishment
doesn't last oawatu eventually returns
from the dead and relieves fury of his
duties
steve rogers isn't in the falcon in the
winter soldier but his legacy looms
large over the entire series
after donating steve's shield to the
smithsonian institution sam wilson and
james rhodes aka war machine
take a walk through the museum's captain
america exhibit the fictional exhibit is
dominated by steve's world war ii
exploits the motorcycle on the prop
shield he used during uso shows as seen
in captain america the first avenger
figure prominently look a little closer
and you'll also see a picture of the 4f
classification that originally kept
steve rogers from enlisting
among other doodads and mementos the
most important artifact however is
captain america comics number one
this item is much bigger than the mcu of
course and exists in our world as well
this 1941 comic written by joe simon and
drawn by jack kirby contains captain
america and bucky's debut
its cover which depicts cap punching
hitler in the jaw was considered
particularly bold at the time
the comic came out a year before america
officially entered the war and its
overtly political message inspired so
much public anger simon and kirby were
assigned police protection
the first episode of the series
introduces a new threat to the mcu
the flag smashers the flag smashers are
a group of terrorists who fight for a
world without borders and believe that
life in the mcu is better during the
blip
as you probably guessed the
flagsmasher's origin comes from the
comics
although the original flagsmasher is a
single man not an organization
carl morgenthau is a skilled martial
artist who dreams of being a diplomat
when carl's father is killed however the
young activist decides that violence is
the only way to achieve peace
he thus adopts the moniker flag smasher
and begins a one-man terror operation
so far that's pretty different from the
falcon and the winter soldiers take on
the flag smashers
but don't think it isn't related aaron
kellyman appears in the first episode's
end credits as carly morgenthau a
gender-swapped version of carl
if you look closely you can tell she's
the flag smasher handing out mass during
the bank robbery in switzerland
if you pause the episode when bucky
pulls out his little notebook you'll see
a couple of names familiar to fans of
marvel comics and one established mcu
villain
helmut zemo is a sokovian terrorist who
first appeared in captain america civil
war
he framed the winter soldier for the
death of black panther's father which
kicked off the film's namesake civil war
between the avengers
other notable names on the list include
aerostar most likely andre rustoff aka
the red barbarian an old iron man
villain there's also w
hausa a possible reference to captain
willem hausa a nazi soldier who appeared
in a nick fury comic in 1966.
prolific marvel comics writer len
kaminsky co-creator of war machine's
armor also gets a shout out
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the falcon and the winter soldier coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you